cool you've got your own other
quadrilateral or your other shape over
here it's a quadrilateral if you came in
a little bit later
this is absolutely any quadrilateral as
weird and unusual as possible now I want
you to do exactly the same thing get
your ruler out and I want you to mark
out all of the midpoints mark out all of
the midpoints go ahead
measure them in fact I'm gonna have to
do this for some my longer sides because
I can't do it by eye measure out find
all the midpoints and then join them all
up and then see what happens and also
try and have one that this is different
to the person next to you so that you
can see this pattern it's really quite
beautiful okay
[Music]
have you noticed what you may do you
notice what you made I'm almost there
well yeah what is going on
okay did you make the shape did you make
the shape let's give this shape a name
I'm gonna call it p q r s what shape is
PQRS it's uh depending on the kind of
quadrilateral you drew you'll get a
slightly different PQRS but all of you
every single one no matter what ABCD you
begin with your PQRS will be a
parallelogram okay which is kind of
weird and crazy in fact you can make
really ridiculous looking quadrilaterals
right we're we're so used to thinking of
polygons as convex everything faces
outwards right but you can have weirder
guys like this watch what happens I'm
even going to do it quite roughly cuz
you can see what's going on midpoint
midpoint midpoint midpoint does that
look okay did I do it by eye all right
and then watch that 1 2 3 4 it's kind of
creepy
how does it do that what's going on okay
now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
give you a couple minutes to think my
tip for you is to do this nice and
easily there's lots of ways to do it
that's one of the great things about
geometry it requires a lot of creativity
imagination because always multiple ways
to prove something my big tip for you is
the re the result we just proved over
here will help you a lot it's one of the
quickest and most efficient ways to show
that indeed PQRS has to be a
parallelogram so I'm gonna let this
settle in your mind and think about how
you might be able to find this over here
because it's hiding in there if you can
find it I'll give you a few minutes to
have a play yeah I did say before I did
to say before that one of the things
that is both most wonderful but also
most challenging about geometry real
geometry is really requires so much
creativity you like you have to imagine
things that aren't there and you have to
think of you've got to come up with ways
of looking at something which you've
never done before we've talked about
this before their problems rather than
exercises almost always so I'm going to
provide a construction in here my tip is
remember over here we've got a
triangle that is formed from joining
midpoints over here okay now we've
clearly joined a lot of midpoints in
this diagram so we should expect that
there's a continuity between them but
the triangles that I've got at the
moment like for example there's a
triangle up here try and go over here
here and here those triangles don't look
like the triangle that we drew over
there you see how this triangles kind of
been like sliced down the middle right
these triangles aren't sliced down the
middle there's no there's no middle in
here or over here so where is the
triangle that's being sliced hmm so this
is where the construction has come in
now just before I do this you'll note
I'm using a different color I also have
a comically large diagram you will find
creativity is helped when you have a big
canvas to work on if you have to work on
this tiny little postage stamp it's very
difficult to draw stuff on it or see
what's going on colors also help because
they can distinguish different features
I'm going to join up the diagonals of
our original quadrilateral can you see
them there look at your original shape
the original four-sided figure that you
drew I want you to look at the diagonals
there it get your ruler out and join
them up with another color if you can
I'm going to join them up like this
okay so here are my diagonals and what I
want you to notice I'm gonna do this
with more colors is that if you have a
look say at the top half up here or
maybe in the top quarter okay all right
triangle a B D do you notice it's just
like the triangle we were working with
it's been sliced in half okay and it's
got these whoops wrong color it's got
these equal sides here and here here and
here are you okay with that so therefore
it should fit the pattern we noticed
before of creating these parallel lines
because the interval joining those
midpoints is parallel to the other side
the one you haven't used so therefore I
can say this side is parallel to this
side or intervals I should say does that
make sense like it's
I'm not going to rehearse that proof
because we just proved it so I can I can
look at that and I can see it right but
now just pretend that this part of the
diagram doesn't exist look at this
bottom part over here
do you notice it's exactly the same
setup but upside down do you see it
triangle what's it called BCD basically
this big one is the same all look my
triangles been cut into two because of
and by the way this is going to be
useful for you particularly the last
thing I'm going to show you today you
start running out of like markings
besides because you like I've got too
many things that are equal so once you
get to three I stopped putting dashes
and I start labeling you know how Roman
numerals
they used like letters right so these
actually look a lot like Roman numerals
one and two and three
so I mark these sides as four like that
whatever convention you like put stars
or crosses or whatever just so long as
you can tell them apart
so therefore you can see that not only
is this sign a parallel to this interval
but in this lower triangle here this
side is parallel to this interval see it
for the same reason but in a different
triangle so now if you forget about this
guy then you've got those opposite sides
of PQRS being parallel
and it doesn't take too much thought to
realize you can rehearse this argument
but at an angle you can say this guy's
parallel to this one same reason this
guy is sorry I need more arrows this guy
is parallel to this one for the same
reason in that triangle so now when I
get rid of this construction in the
middle with my really messy finger you
can see tada I don't need to say
anything else that's the definition of a
parallelogram okay and you can even do
it over here with this weed shape